[Musica]
grande appassionato di moto
non si può cominciare a parlare di moto
vi porterò all'inizio in un piccolissimo
Viaggio nel tempo
vi Chi ha voglia e chiude gli occhi Ci
spostiamo dal 2022 al 2011
siamo a Jerez domenica
gara di MotoGp piove inaspettatamente
Valentino Rossi che in quel momento non
era nella fase migliore della sua
carriera
fa il warm up e secondo
che è un risultato straordinario perché
sull'asciutto era molto molto in
difficoltà
parte la gara alle 2 parte da molto
indietro era oltre la decima posizione
decimo nono VIII
quarto terzo
vede Stoner davanti
è molto vicino sta recuperando con una
grandissima velocità
vede un passaggio
si infila lo c'entra cadono tutti e due
disastro
i marceli aiutano in realtà aiutano Vale
e si scatenavano polemiche enorme perché
case non riesce a ripartire con l'onda
vale finisce la gara arriva quinto
e comincia una polemica comincia la
polemica perché
quando Stoner torna al box si cambia
Vale rientra c'ha la tuta
e con la tuta ancora va nel box della
Honda da Stoner a scusarsi perché
ovviamente è stato un errore grave
e lì parte una frase che è rimasta
celebre per chiunque sia appassionato di
moto che calza perfettamente con il tema
della giornata che
vale pensava che Stoner accettasse le
scuse quindi ha detto Mi scuso se vengo
con il casco in testa e che gli dice Io
ora Mission Talent
che è estremamente pesante ma mi dà
l'opportunità di parlare di questo che
secondo me è un punto estremamente
interessante che lo Sweet Spot lo
chiamerei io fra l'ambizione e la
possibilità
perché negli interventi che ci hanno
preceduto che mi hanno preceduto è un
tema che è stato trattato ma l'ambizione
è troppo ambiziosa Questa persona è poco
ambiziosa il primo speaker trattato bene
questo punto troppo ambizioso perché era
troppo focalizzato sui risultati
economici poco ambizioso perché era in
un qualche modo troppo focalizzato sulla
famiglia io vorrei portare un concetto
diverso che
questo switch spot non dipende solo
dall'ambizione ma dipende
fortissimamente dalla possibilità e
proverò a spiegare un po' meglio questo
concetto
il pilota ha una frazione di secondo per
decidere nel momento che vuole
effettuare quella manovra se la sua
ambizione è possibile dipende dalla
distanza che ha rispetto al pilota che
lo precede in quell'ingresso di curva
Dipende da quanto lui ha un po' più di
grip rispetto al pilota che lo precede
Quindi pensa di poter effettuare questa
manovra in un modo più veloce ogni
sorpasso si effettua in questo modo io
arrivo Sono vicino guardo È chiaro che
se pensi di poter superare un pilota che
mi precede penso di avere una
possibilità di percorrere quella manovra
in un modo più veloce o perché ho più
talento
o perché in un qualche modo ha consumato
meno le gomme e le gomme permettono di
farlo perché è una moto migliore ma ho
solo una frazione di secondo per poterlo
decidere
il manager l'imprenditore
ha un grande vantaggio che è il tempo e
al tempo per poter decidere se la
propria ambizione è adeguata o anche il
tempo per costruirsi la possibilità
e costruirsi la possibilità
significa effettuare un lavoro o su se
stesso come persona o se l'ambizione e
l'ambizione del brand e l'ambizione
della marca nella costruzione della
squadra
l'azienda per cui lavora una Vision
estremamente ambiziosa perché abbiamo la
vision di essere il marchio più
desiderato nel mondo dei motociclisti
Quindi
si può dire è troppo ambiziosa si può
dire presuntuosa
Ma secondo me non si può dire in
assoluto se non c'è dubbio non si
giudica rispetto alla possibilità e non
si giudica rispetto alla capacità di
esprimere così Intendo per possibilità
Intendo la capacità della persona del
founder se è la startup o del gruppo se
la startup o dell'azienda nel caso che
un'azienda di dimensioni già cresciuta
come quella per cui lavorano di poter
raggiungere o meno questa Vision
è evidente che sulla possibilità c'è
tanta possibilità di lavorare c'è tanta
possibilità di costruire
Noi stiamo in un percorso che ci rende
estremamente confidenti che questa
Vision la raggiungeremo perché siamo
così confidenti poter raggiungere questa
bici perché lavoriamo sulla possibilità
cioè Costruiamo una squadra che sia in
grado di raggiungere questa vigile e
costruire una squadra significa
applicare un modello applicare un metodo
che un metodo che si basa su almeno due
concetti che vi vorrei in qualche modo
esprimere il primo e che questa Vision
sia perfettamente Chiara e condivisa a
tutte le persone che la devono eseguire
la condivisione della vision e
l'esplicitazione di questa bici in una
strategia che sia una strategia poi
Chiara enunciata e che la strategia ne
venga fatto il deployment e il
deployment è una delle cose più
complicate e più trascurate perché molte
strategie sono buone Ma poi falliscono
nell'execution e quindi non era
l'ambizione che era sbagliata Ma che non
c'era in qualche modo Una ricostruzione
adeguata fra l'ambizione e la
realizzazione dell'ambizione il
deployment della strategia per darvi
qualche spot per noi significa scrivere
una lista di kpi cioè di indicatori che
noi vogliamo raggiungere nel 2025 nel
2030 e fare in modo che i piani vengano
poi declinati per area la nostra
organizzazione è piccola per il mondo ma
è già complessa per il nostro paese
anche complesso da gestire Quindi siamo
in 2500 persone quindi ha bisogno di
un'organizzazione per fare in modo che
questa ambizione abbia una possibilità
di essere raggiunta e quindi la
declinazione dei kpi si divide per area
e ha un tracking mensile Questa è la
parte se vogliamo più
complicata perché ha bisogno di un
execution è un po' come se fosse non so
come dire gestione quindi non è la
vision ma è la gestione
dell'applicazione della strategia
all'interno dell'azienda
la seconda tematica che è estremamente
importante è che qualsiasi strategia
qualsiasi vision e qualsiasi strategia
implementazione non è realizzabile se
banalmente le persone che sono attorno
non sono della qualità quantità e
allineamento adeguato e Noi lo chiamiamo
il concetto di uso on the Bus quindi chi
è sull'autobus Chi è chi è nella squadra
del people on the Bus Made the
difference
e quindi
c'è una un'attività estremamente
continua dettagliata di gestione del
team per noi il nostro gruppo di lavoro
è visto come fossimo una squadra
sportiva di alto livello quindi una
squadra di serie A e quindi chiunque
gioca con noi deve giocare
al livello di una squadra di serie A Che
significa che deve avere il talento e
quindi auspicabilmente l'abbiamo
selezionato nel modo giusto di aver
voglia di allenarsi
in modo estremamente determinato deve
allenarsi come un calciatore di serie A
deve aver voglia di mangiare quello che
serve deve avere voglia di fare tutta la
parte di fitness adeguata e di aver
voglia di giocare per la squadra
queste caratteristiche hanno bisogno di
essere costantemente
gestite e devono essere costantemente
controllate quindi deve esserci una
panchina deve esserci Un allenatore
che ha anche il fegato e la possibilità
di prendere anche un giocatore di
talento rinomato magari conosciuto che
in quel momento non è trapelato
adeguatamente o che non è in un momento
adeguato alla sua carriera e metterlo in
panchina la gestione della squadra è
un'attività estremamente complessa per
quello che riguarda la possibilità vi
ricordate l'ambizione all'ambizione
rispetto alla possibilità Dov'è lo Sweet
Spot lo Sweet Spot dipende da Qual è la
mia possibilità di squadra in un certo
momento rispetto alla mia ambizione
per noi questa attività di gestione del
team è
altrettanto importante come la
costruzione della strategia la strategia
dipende dalla Vision la visione chiara
non l'abbiamo mai cambiata la strategia
continuiamo ad aggiornarla in termini di
kpi ogni tre anni perché in realtà il
mondo è estremamente dinamico le cose
cambiano molto rapidamente quello che
poteva essere vero cinque anni fa
Certamente è totalmente non più veloce
fondamentalmente nel mondo della
tecnologia e le cose cambiano con una
velocità straordinaria quindi la
strategia viene rivista ogni tre anni
per i kpi e la squadra viene gestita in
continuazione
Io penso che questa bici noi abbiamo una
probabilità importante di realizzarla ci
sentiamo bene ci sentiamo bene come
squadra abbiamo una grande
attività e abbiamo una grande in qualche
modo capacità di lavoro sulla squadra
stessa
siamo un'azienda orgogliosamente
italiana siamo un'azienda che lavora
moltissimo con le università siamo
un'azienda che ha un rapporto diretto e
per creare in continuazione persone che
entrano all'interno abbiamo una
filosofia di crescita dall'interno molto
importante E questo ci rende in qualche
modo eh orgogliosamente italiani sono
davvero in qualche modo felice di aver
ascoltato delle belle storie qua eh Sono
contento che ci siano molti alti ragazzi
giovani eh che vogliono cominciare un
percorso in questa nostra Italia che è
così in qualche modo spesso anche non
portata a livello in cui dovrebbe essere
abbiamo visto la copertina di ieri di
cui abbiamo visto tutti i giornali con
questa Inghilterra con delle grandi
difficoltà e che dovendo la paragonare a
qualcuno che non è capace di
organizzarci di gestirsi cioè il solito
in qualche modo eh giochino della pizza
e degli altri oggetti quindi
orgogliosamente italiano yogurt Un
grande in bocca al lupo a tutti i
ragazzi giovani che sono qua e grazie di
avermi ascoltato Grazie ancora